viola
aurait
recours à deux
premiers qui n'est pas de taxer le
support vous n'êtes pas bien sûr non non
non c'est super bien et ce poids là
proches du pouvoir n'est ce pas là pour
ce jeudi
les sit in
à la
3g pas droite pourquoi j'ai pas toi tu
penses que tout coureur faisant quelque
là vous avez du mal à monter et alors à
quand je suis dans che dans au bond d'un
coup de chance comment je fais mes
béquilles mais drac ne sont même pas
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en
étable comme les taxis mais c'est pas
moi qui conduis moi je prends pas
là commence à agacer débrouille toi mais
je te dit tu touches pas tu me touches
pas la forêt
qui m'accompagne cognac rue du retrait
de renard 2
g dormir un petit peu je dois
ouf enfin je pense je monte devant je
suis malade à l'arrière
avec toi c'est pas d'accord d'accord
allez madame
[Musique]
on y recense lui
oui ni non non non non non ne ressentait
pas non vous n'êtes pas ensemble et si
depuis trois semaines
atteint sont des latins doucement six
mois vomir comme a fait sentir on
essaiera de l'est pourraient
complètement n'ont pas complètement
regardez moi tu regarde regarde aller tu
vois bien que je suis pas bourré
complètement olala
bouton attention et le préfet molle
alors pourquoi s'est pas attaché ces
taxis mais pas pour les ivrognes ne
s'est pas une ivrogne on le croit
l'écouté
mais qu'est ce qui se fait et se fera du
dégât d'accord
[Musique]